hi i'm christopher hine today we're
going to be talking about khan renwazza
so
conrad means adaptive and this is a a
field in aikido which is generally
really neglected so an adaptive
technique is a technique that teaches
you how to change from one thing into
the next thing
and unfortunately for most aikido
schools when they're teaching
aikido they teach it as if that one
technique will always work so if you
were to master that technique then it
would always work 100 of the time
and this is just not true depending upon
the physicality and the skill of the
person you're dealing with
you're probably going to have to adapt
your technique to something else
in sport martial arts this is not a
thing right so all sport martial arts
teach around this concept of how do you
adapt when they defend against what
you're doing in aikido we don't talk
about it a lot now that's historically
not true
there are several aikido teachers who
have done works on khan renwazza
adaptive techniques
psychosense in particular in traditional
aikido has a good section on
conor nawaza but these are the
techniques that you use to adapt when
someone's not doing what they're
supposed to do
in the form so i'm gonna get josh out
here we're gonna work for you guys josh
okay so we're going to talk a little bit
about conran i'm going to pick one
form and we're going to go through some
of the conroe that come up for that form
the form we're going to take is
shomanuchi
omote because it's a common form however
i have a ton of chondren i teach through
conrad generally so meaning what i
generally do is i teach a form
and then i watch the class and then i
see what uh help they need with the con
where they're needing conrad and then i
teach those in there as we go and so
that's generally the way i teach so
if you want to see a set of these i can
teach you a full giant set of these
but this will give you the idea of where
we're going with it now
understand i covered this in a video
that's on youtube you can check out
but you know a form is comprised of many
techniques
so when we look at the form of
shomanichi ikiyomote let's look at the
techniques in there because each one of
these techniques
could have a problem and that's where
we'd have to apply the conrad
so the formula look at shomunuchi omote
so here's our shomonucci that's our
first technique right so you could
either look at it as the um
the defense right here or you could look
at it as the shomonucci but that's our
our first technique our second
is the ikkyo proper which is controlled
the elbow right there so
now i have an ekill beginning to go and
i'm doing this ikyo in an
omote fashion which means i'm driving to
the front as opposed to driving to the
rear right so
um or moving to the rear and if i did it
to the rear they would call that urawaza
which means receptive but right now i'm
doing this omote which means
front direct so this echo is being done
in no multi fashion
then i would continue this in until we
got here which is the udeo se
and udeo se just means arm pin so this
is our arm pin right here
and then from here i would begin to take
him down right and then we'd have a iose
which is just the the pin that happens
on the ground so that would be the full
form for this
now each one of those technical parts
could
need conrad which is an adaptation
because he's doing something
so let's look at uh the first one which
is uh ikyo
to konren iriminage so
ikyokonren iminage so the shomenuchikiyo
is happening
now normally what happens in a show manu
cheeky at this point is my partner stays
facing me like this and i drive into him
and that'll take his balance but my
partner could turn his back to me
right so just like this okay now a lot
of times you'll get this when you're
getting someone new or someone who wants
to be a jerk or whatever and they're
trying to resist your echo
and so what they'll do is if i'm trying
to drive this guy forward and he turns
his back towards me
right like this ah you see more and more
and more it's really difficult you see
as i started to do it josh just turned
his back to me more and more and more
and this makes it really really
difficult for me
right okay so what you do in this
situation and stay uh
really upright we'll talk about the
other one later but so as i start to do
this and he stays
real upright like this i'm going to take
the idi minake now the idi mi nag is
right here
okay so it's a super easy eating me nage
because he's
giving it to me like literally giving it
to me so if we go to the front here
let's go just a little bit this way okay
so i'm driving into this guy and he
turns his back
now look to get him nugget all i've got
to do is slide the echo hand over here
that will release him he'll stand bolt
upright which is what he wants to do and
i come right through here
and we get idimi nagi off of that so the
idimi nage conrans
really naturally from the ikyo if
they're turning their back like that so
if you get a guy who's doing that a lot
you're going to get the idi minage
so that's where we're having a problem
with our ikyo and it conrans
okay now in that same uh same technical
problem set
so we could be here and he could be
pushing directly against me like this
right so oh he's really pushing against
me and that's because he's so strongly
he can just
force himself back down like that okay
he's just pushing right up against me
okay so now we're going to use ikkyo
so we're going to ikyo we're going to
adapt that ikyo into a kokinagi so as
he's pushing into me i let that go by
and i step in here and i get the
kokinagi
so again you see how naturally this sets
up he's pushing i let that go right over
my head like this
this pushes his hips sorry this pushes
his hips into my hips
and i step right through that imbalance
right so he does it to himself ninety
percent of the time he comes in i hit my
hips right here boom
and then i just drive right through him
for the kolkynage so that's
right so that's how you would adapt in
that situation we could also have a
situation
where he just drives his elbows straight
down like that right so look he took my
ikea away
now he didn't drive into me enough that
i could get the kokinage so here this
would be hard to get a coke nugget not
gonna work
he doesn't turn his back towards me at
all so i'm not gonna get the the eating
me
but here when he drops this i can turn
out so sotomori and what this is going
to do is it's going to give me the space
here which is what i want and as he
comes around
we get kodagaish so that's
okay and it happens because we're here
he just steals his elbow away i turn to
the outside
and there gives us a kodagaish right so
there's another adaptation all those
adaptations are happening because
he's resisting my echo proper right so
when i'm trying to do this and trying to
go omote either one he turns his back
to me right i get the idi minage two he
pushes against me and i get the kolkya
nage
three he steals his elbow and i get the
kodagaish right
so you can see that's how we adapt each
one of those so this is just the first
this we could do it for each stage of
this ikea
we'd have a really really long video if
we did that and we can do it for every
aikido technique we have so
that's what khan renwazza is and that's
different than uh kaishiwaza and
different than
it's like a kaishiwaza is to change a
technique over right so
if say joshua's applying uh kodagaish to
me right so
yeah it doesn't matter he applied code
guys to me and so then i apply kodagashi
to him
that's kaishi that's to turn it over so
meaning he does a technique to me and i
do it back to him
conrad's different it's an adaptation
meaning i do something to him
he changes the situation so i move with
that change
and do another technique so that's the
basic idea of conran waza
[Music]